you were improvising tons of bits about
like the allure of the Opel I love that
you say the dinosaurs stands yeah you
know like that the idea that a dinosaur
has a conscious thinks about finds
precious stones and looks at them hello
I'm Adam Sandler one of the stars of
uncut gems
I'm Josh safty I'm Benny safty the
writers and directors watching a single
or breaking it down for you right yeah
check this out
oh no all right so these are black Jews
the problem with doing this is that I
just want to watch the scene yeah as
soon as I hit play
[Music]
alright the stranded in the middle of
Ethiopia Steve yeah look good they've
got enough
Howard showing Kevin something rkg
something that shows how deep this opal
right first of all one of the greatest
lines ever it comes before is is a camel
so I'm watching The History Channel
trying to learn because I love that
Howard that's an education Howard era
but but this scene this sequence
remember when we were you were hanging
out with Todd one of the people you were
trailing he had that different vibe when
he was in the when he was that sure yeah
you're kind of in your sing-songy yeah
yeah this is Howard when he's selling
and you guys went where to shoot that
that we we were we were shooting we went
down to South Africa cuz they wouldn't
let us shoot it in Ethiopia the US
government actually wouldn't we shot
that in Oh keep South Africa when I
before sundown while we were shooting
the beginning introduction in Africa its
ownit over there it's everywhere right
well if these guys get precious black
opals that's what that is
so black opal I do my research these
guys live near the whale of mine and the
Torah pointer has some opals black opals
I just love the idea that a jeweler can
be watching The History Channel right
and feel like he's getting the edge on
other Kevin here so interested in you
gotta say we had a show him he says
these guys live near the whale on mines
which primarily is red opals which
aren't worth Oh
but these yeah you can't get your hands
on understand this was like one of the
first big scenes with Kevin right this
yes yes yes and man was he smooth and
relaxed in this scene it's tough you
like write in the script cagey becomes
captivated instantly by the colors of
the opal right right and that's tough
for any actor to do because it's an
inanimate object
well so look I say to my son I like that
he's interested in Howard story how I
could sell ice to an Eskimo the way you
pull it up Daria is called you Houdini
how it is like Houdini Rock that's the
stones look how this is wink
just in the moment where you realize
Julie is actually rooting for you all
the time took me 17 months to in this
moment you've got five different people
you're looking at you looking at Kevin
look at Julie everybody remember how
much we did making this opal how many
times when we shot that one version that
we didn't like I had to convince the
Australians they came to let us use some
of these about $150 when you brought the
opal on the set finally it was the
biggest yeah we finally got the real oh
it was like we've unearthed it from the
ground just look at this hang out for a
second go through my look big care
that's my best all right I want you to
look
right here this is it this is my from
actually Todd's favorite Luke yeah and
he knows he's asked while we were
shooting it the props he kept calling us
because hey that's my favorite loop one
of the guys sandler trailed for the
movie was this guy Todd Bobby oh it was
really great character and that was his
loop and I remember when we finished
yeah when we wrap but that's like a big
look and is it great I love that you
wanted to internalize that we were doing
research like and it's also it's a big
deal it's how you you sell it to Kevin
like here he is holding one of the most
expensive rocks a million dollars back
I'm worried about the loop what all
5,000 carats $3,000 - Karen oh oh
Vasek got so many colors in it what is
this from stone to stone Garnett to
stone you know that's a stone that's a
million dollar hopefully straight from
the big Jewish tribe you were like we
got the guy's last name is a stone we
got it I mean this is old-school
middle-earth dinosaur Judas
you were improvising tons of bits about
like the allure of the Opel I love that
you say the dinosaurs you know like that
the idea that a dinosaur has a conscious
I think about finds precious stones
[Music]
ining these these journeys were so
difficult because a lot of the effects
people work off of things that are
already been created Rises
yeah there's no reference so you're
pulling lots of space imagery and and
still images but there's a guy there's a
guy in LA that's microphotography so
building these things and it's tough
because when you're on set you know you
just say oh then you know in the script
you write the Cameron dives into the gem
right I still get I still get a little
little stoned every time watching this
you have all these images that are there
a flashing from Kevin's glass like and
it was I said to Kevin you got any
pictures of your oh so so we had to
source them through people who he's
known over the years it's amazing that
everybody was kind of game for this all
of you we were sitting in the corner of
this of the set and we had the special
effects guy off to the side and we
didn't tell anybody when we were going
to break the glass remember we just did
it on this has a button by the button so
we were just letting you guys go and you
were talking with Kevin everybody was
getting comfortable and we waited until
that last time well yeah it was loud
yeah we shot this it with two cameras
actually so we have this wide shot here
that you see
the way that you react Kevin I do we may
we have that jacket for a reason in this
it's funny because Kevin looks at the
jam and sees the journey there's that
moment Howard looks at the gym and
doesn't see anything but it's because
Howard is the jam you know that self
reflection but yeah Howard another gem
is the thing that has perceived no value
and there's flaws on the outside we got
a scope down underneath it to get to you
know it's the flaws that make it
beautiful too I mean without that that
scene doesn't work the movie doesn't
work thanks for watching our seed
breakdown yes thank you enjoy the movie
you see it I'll be sure to get your
tickets for uncut jams on fan deck yes
available now I have a couple of coupons
if you want
[Music]